guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
thank you guys great clapping
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in and as you guys
already know if you have watched two or
more of my videos and you don't
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
uh a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is that we have
two clips channels just Pearl eclipse
and pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both also guys um we have
four membership tiers the first tier
lets you be a part of our live chat
today blessing how many likes to open up
the chat today
uh blessing says a thousand likes to
open up the chat so a thousand it is if
you don't like that number you know put
a put a 10 in the black a 10 in the chat
to blame blessing okay also guys um
second tier you get to access our
Discord and our behind the scenes Vlogs
um if you want to see me freestyle rap
sign up for the second tier also guys
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media a fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month how
do you get a million subscribers in a
year I will tell you sign up for the
fourth tier also if you want to start a
live show I can give you a lot of tips
and advice and just save you a lot of
headaches so I really recommend that
fourth tier also guys they took away my
Instagram so go follow up my new
Instagram just pearly things one there's
also an Instagram account pretending to
be me um no I'm not selling you crypto
no I'm not trying to date any of you
like like if I'm yeah okay please
um Rumble Rumble uh we are on Rumble so
go subscribe to rumble also guys wife
school
um we are going to be doing lessons and
how to be a more traditional wife um
this is where I go through different
lessons so I learned how to knead bread
the other day
um you know we did the fashion episode
yeah yeah
um you know we just do different
episodes on that um I think uh Maggie is
a substitute teacher came in and we did
an episode where I would cook what you
would cook for a husband in a day so
also guys uh we did the Meetup already
just pearly animations is our animations
Channel um we have one official pregame
page on Instagram so go sign up for that
also go follow its complicated channels
sometimes we get um our questions from
him and we are going to do a Members
Only video for um the penthouse tour so
we have a whole pen it's a cool
Penthouse right guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
so if you guys want to see it and you
want to see what a full-on Production
Studio looks like um sign up for that
okay thank you that's a lot of
announcements
um so today we have a lovely panel um
why don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact either about the world or
yourself either or
um so starting here and then go around
um my name is Kina
um Kiki underscore chi on Instagram and
um I'm 20.
um I live in London and fun facts I'm a
twin
are you guys identical no I don't know
he's a guy
um my name is Sakina I'm 28 years old in
a relationship and fun fact about me
um I once met someone really famous
while I was on the plane and they came
and spoke to me and I didn't actually
know who he was
um yeah
did you find out who he was
um afterwards yeah but I didn't know who
he was in the beginning he was just like
a very famous Bollywood actor oh that
happened to me that happened to me with
um who was it it was
oh my gosh I can't remember I still
can't remember yeah
she was like a really big R B artist but
I don't listen to that type of music
yeah
dear last thing you remember who it was
oh Erica Badoo okay yeah I've heard of
her but I don't actually know what she
looks like so I wouldn't know who she is
either and I just I don't listen to that
I also the country so it's just a
different holiday
um okay go ahead uh hi my name is Andrea
oh dear oh
what do you want to call me I'm 23. uh
I'm From Doncaster and fun fact well I'm
way too straightforward
[Laughter]
[Music]
go ahead hey guys I'm Laura I'm 21 based
in shuffled and fun fact um
Slovakian I guess
I think that's quite um exciting
yeah okay go ahead
Troy Francis 47 years young I'm a dating
coach uh what is my relationship status
painfully single haven't met the right
woman yet no sadly
in time guys in time and uh fun facts
about me uh I'm a big fan of Eastern
Europe actually
um I like to travel around Eastern
Europe uh places like Hungary Poland
um obviously Ukraine in a place like
that before the conflict so yeah it's
all good that's good okay
I'm Lucy I'm from Ireland but I live in
London now I'm 23 and an interesting
fact about me is that a goat broke my
cheekbone in two places when I was 18.
he's called Bojangles lovely goat but
are you still friends oh yeah
actually he did die this year but yeah
oh okay I mean loving a bit we're good
yeah yeah that's fair enough
so today's topic
I actually forgot what we titled it
modern women as if modern women are
crappy wives okay that's what I thought
today's topic I'm gonna do it again
modern women are crappy wives
so um today my first question is do you
want to be a wife yes and if so
what makes a good wife so starting here
and I go wow
what makes a good wife
um I think companionship like definitely
friendship I think that's a big thing in
a marriage
um I wouldn't know that because I'm not
married but you know something I want is
to be literally my partner's best friend
um
oh do you think men want a best friend
yeah 100 100 okay yeah really I
yeah even me it's not all the time but
okay okay anything else
um
just just to be there to show up okay
yeah women don't have to do anything but
be a best friend and show up to be a
wife okay not just that okay
so I'm just gonna go off of what you say
so
um
just I I don't know okay I just um
because we live in this in a society
like this it doesn't like cooking and
like traditional things I I don't even
feel like it should be like you know
divide should be half yeah divided
definitely so I don't think it's like a
compulsory thing do you think all the
like fixing stuff around the house
should be divided half half fixing the
car
um
so the dates be half half I'm just I'm
just you know we're gonna this is the
energy right yeah and that would be a
good wife
yeah I'll split the chores with you I'll
be your best friend yes okay okay go
ahead
um what do I think a wife do you want to
be a wife and What Makes a Good Wife
yeah I do want to be a wife
um I would say what makes a good wife is
being the type of woman that can
motivate and inspire a man to be the
best version of himself because I feel
like with a good woman by his side
supporting him a man can do incredible
things and I some I feel like some men
are lacking
that in their lives like they're like
they don't have that woman that's there
guiding them and like being supportive
and motivating him and lifting him up
um so how would a girl do that
just inspiring a man to be the best
version of himself like
um how
so like if I said I wanna I wanna I
wanna be a good wife and I'm coming to
you how can I inspire
well I feel like you
you have to be a good woman yourself
first like you have to be
like you have to be basically having
your own things like you have to be
independent you have to be like cultured
worldly intellectual
um you have to have things that also
Inspire the man and I feel like when you
have those things as a woman you can
bring those into the relationship and
the man sees you he sees your worth he
sees your value and he's like I've got
to step my game up like I've got to be
the best man for her
um because you inspire him to be like
that you know and where did you learn
this is this from your parents or did
you learn it somewhere else
uh because I've learned it from my
parents yeah I did I think my mum really
helped my dad become the best version of
himself she helped him on the straight
road she made him cut out a lot of toxic
how did you do that
um because of her morals like she had
real strong morals he saw her value he
saw what type of woman she was and he
wanted to lock it down straight away he
was like this is like a real good woman
like she's you know there for me she's
supporting me she's trying to help me
build she wants to help me build this
Empire so I've got to get my act
together so yeah I did watch my mom and
dad like that because my question is
more you said independent and I just
when in history have Independent Women
have men wanted Independent Women
like what men have always wanted women
yeah that relied on them when I'm when
I'm in sorry I just want to rephrase
that when I meant independent I meant as
in like she is able to stand on her own
two feet like she doesn't need him she's
not constantly needing him she doesn't
give off that like needy clinginess like
she can do things around on her own but
she would rather let the man do things
for her if that makes sense but if he
wasn't around and God forbid something
happened then she'd be able to stand on
her own two feet because I feel like men
do want that they don't want to know
that you like
constantly like need them emotionally
mentally everything I've never heard a
guy say that he doesn't want a girl that
needs him but there's so many guys that
get turned off by it you know if they
don't like you
if like usually it's like a girl that's
like a little bit too ugly for him like
typically like she's a little bit below
his typical league and like that's why
she's annoying to him because she's not
in his like
League
yeah like have you ever seen a guy that
was into a girl that's like oh she's too
needy she wants me too much
I mean I have heard men say that but
yeah I guess maybe bear with the wrong
woman I guess I don't know okay okay
what do you think well I think the woman
needs to look after the house I think
she have to
um be there for him like to support him
and I think the friendship is important
as well
um I don't know the respect as well
okay so you think she should take care
of the house she's respectful to him
yeah friendship I think that's important
okay they can be friends they can do
things together they can even house
things they can do together okay all
right go ahead it's a weird one for me
well do you want to be a wife and did
you say do you want you want to do it
well it's a tricky one for me because I
actually was a wife okay uh but now I'm
single so yeah I want to be a wife okay
all right go ahead sorry I just love
love I love love
um
I kind of like the idea of
being a wife equaling things if that
makes sense like paying for dates
supporting our family supporting our
house when it comes to building stuff I
don't think so I like it though
um so you'll have the money yeah you'll
do 50 50 on the money but again I I
understand it comes to some extents
obviously we get pregnant we
um leave obviously because we are with
child
um
so I like the way you said that yeah
how can I phrases
um
what's your question actually what makes
a good what makes a good wife makes a
good wife morals morals and I think
would you include like loyalty in that
absolutely okay so you'd say a woman's a
bad wife if she leaves no right no I I
disagree yeah but then how are you a
good wife if you leave
well if you don't have the reason to
stay you you have to leave you know
commitment vows
[Laughter]
you look like
um to be married and to have a family
like I think that's beautiful and it can
be beautiful
um it's it's commit it's a commitment
and it's hard
and I feel like a lot of people
don't like to go through the hardship
but the hardship makes you stronger but
the good wives go through the hardship
and the bad wives leave no
was asking her but you can
um
think about that one I'm just I'm trying
to I'm trying to understand I don't know
like this don't just think if you're
good at something you get it done yeah I
feel like
um
it goes down to like being a team
you know and like working on things
together and progressing the
relationship together you know so if
someone's slacking
far enough and if it is a long period of
time or it does affect the relationship
or you know
then you got to cut it basically all
right all right what do you think makes
it good actually I'm gonna do the girls
first and then I'll tell you so what do
you think do you want to be a wife and
what makes a good wife I'm gonna be
controversial and saying not really
don't want to be away no I only want I
would only get married if it was
something that the other person felt
really strongly about but to me
if you're in a relationship and you're
that committed to that person what what
is a marriage going to do like what is
that commitment saying to other people
exactly and if I'm not committed to
someone that I feel like I should be
married to them
unless I believe in the religious
beliefs behind it
I just don't see it as being a bigger
progression in the commitment I should
be committed regardless okay and there
shouldn't be something on paper at a
state that I have to be that way it
should just be a mutual agreement that
you're both just a feeling committed and
committed and nothing's going to change
about that so personally it's not
something that I like
will ever try to force down someone or
something that I really want but if they
feel very passionate about it and I feel
like it's the right time I'm okay with
that okay and it's just something I
don't feel like what do you what do you
think makes a good wife
so
in all honesty I think just being there
as the other half
like I know you discussed about it I've
just made them basically yeah I know you
discussed it as being like you know a
woman has a role in a relationship I'm
actually bisexual so to me it could work
either way okay and to me I feel like 50
50 is where that kind of stuff needs to
fall into place 50 50 on everything
because not necessarily it give and take
okay so if you have to look at the
person's attributes what they give to a
relationship and break it down that way
I don't think it's a one-size-fits all I
don't think everyone can say right
you're going to do this you're going to
do that because you're the man the man
could be he could be really bad at
it you could be amazing at it yeah
perfect let them work to their strengths
I think that's what works in a
relationship when you let the other
person working together yeah sure but I
think there are some things that
regardless whether you're traditional or
not there are some things that
naturally a man might be better a woman
might be better out we're very different
biologically so there's always going to
be things that a man's going to be
slightly better at than a woman unless
they're you're an anomaly and you're
going to be 10 times stronger than the
man that's unlikely so I I think yeah
give or take I think everything has to
be looked up retrospectively and it has
to be broken down about each person's
attributes and what they can give to the
situation so what do you think makes a
woman a good wife
like what's just specific this is just a
bit broad so I'm just trying to kind of
Reign it in you know fair enough
um so being able to provide in a sense
that you can provide emotionally whether
you can provide financially is
irrelevant if the other person can
provide financially perfect you then
need to make up for the other gaps so as
a wife you might need to be able to cook
be able to look after children or be
able to look after man or the man be
able to look after you and you be
receiving to that because I think a lot
of women nowadays look at a relationship
and think the man should have to meet
the first of everything do everything
but that makes a lot of men very not a
lot of men but nowadays it makes them
quite intimidated and then they get
nervous and then they think oh what if I
can't do that you have to be receptive
to what they want to do if they want to
buy food for you let them if they want
to take you out in a day and they want
to pay for everything I'm asking what
does she have to do she has to be
receptive yeah receive what else does
she have to do
um
again see because it's something that I
personally you don't don't yeah I don't
know it's something that I wouldn't
really have values on so I don't really
think what I'm gonna say is going to
give you much much information to be
honest okay no worries all right so
question do you want to be a husband do
I want to be a husband
um I am not enthusiastic about it with
the way that marriage is with laws and
just with the way the culture is in
general
um and I've been that way for a long
time I mean like as it was my parents
divorced when I was a kid so I never
really had a great argument uh you know
a great example for a sort of marriage
and and that kind of thing anyway and
obviously as time's gone on you know
we've seen what's happened in terms of
the way that Society is here in the USA
in Canada and Australia you know those
Western countries it's it's it's not a
good deal to be honest it's never been
something that I've been particularly
keen on I've become less keen on the
idea as I've gone on really now in a
sense I agree with what you said because
I think a long-term relationship fine
commitment fine do you want to put a
ring on it
probably not you know it would have to
be a very good reason for doing it or do
it somewhere else like do it over in um
maybe one of the Lesser you know Latin
American countries or something like
that okay and um out of what did you
hear about who did I marry no no
okay
what did you hear today was there
anything you heard that you thought yes
that would make a good way
I think a lot of the women were
a bit light on specifics to to be honest
you know there's a lot of stuff yeah
support and blah blah blah but there's
there's a lot there wasn't much
specifics in terms of what what is the
woman actually going to bring to the
table so
um I would say that but I mean I I think
really you want somebody who is
gonna support you he's gonna be easy to
be around you know
um and I think marriage worked pretty
well back in the day when things were
more traditional to be honest and I
think now we've come away from that it
just doesn't work as well you know and
um we're seeing that and you know as we
know the majority of divorces are caused
by women you know 70 of divorces are
initiated by women so it's women who are
women which is why modern women are
shitty wives things exactly exactly but
that's another reason another reason I'm
not keen to go into it because for guys
it's a bit of a bad deal because you
know the women are very keen to get
married you know women will try to push
the agenda of like oh you know where are
we are we going to get engaged are we
moving in together we're gonna get
married
but then they get fed up you know 10 15
10 15 years like down the line and they
initiate divorce and then the guy's
screwed so but why is she fed up why is
she fed up I well I think I mean there's
going to be many different reasons for
that and we could go into lots of
different examples but I think a lot of
it is that they lose the the you know
the butterflies go because and it's
inevitably gonna go over a longer period
of time because we all know you have
that honeymoon period and then you know
it gets always yeah yeah then it gets it
gets a bit boring and the problem with
that is that if you're then putting that
into a legal contract where one of the
parties could just say I'll sod that and
walk out that's a Dangerous Ground I
think no like I've got I don't know like
I've just got a thought like obviously
you said woman leave in a marriage of
course which I understand but
I'm 21 like I know I'm still young but I
feel like there's a specific time period
to have kids
and to marry and settle down and I feel
like I don't know like this little
pressure because if I put myself in a
guy's
perspective of shoes like I'm not
burying a child and that changes your
body it does it changes yeah we are of
course we have the biological clock
where we're all aware of it so yeah it's
harder for us I think that's why
probably why we want to lock it down oh
yeah yeah sure sure yeah yeah and like
and like with women leaving again this
is such a broad subject so I'm not I'm
not on about just cheating by the way
yeah
um but yeah one off it's like
I get and understand why men do like
cheese yeah and go for younger women
well what I love it's actually not such
a broad thing though well men don't
typically leave for younger women they
don't even leave no they're just gonna
cheat us today
I mean I think personally I think that
sex is to to men as attention is to
women
so I think women need attention like
like men need sex but women are never
expected to close off their social media
yeah yeah but men are expected to stop
having sex with other girls how's that
fair but women can post ass pics on
their Instagram
nobody can touch it
yeah it's like advertising I mean I was
even looking at okay
what I was looking at was her Instagram
I was like she's married to a world
famous pop star yeah and I know she's a
model right but he's a girl at that
point but he's he's got groupies yeah
and he's also very religious apparently
I know what's going on so it's like
you're married to a world famous pop
star and you still got
look at look at the booty one look at it
yeah look at that yeah okay and the
funny thing is he comments on it as well
so it's bizarre as long as he's okay
with it he's like oh my God yeah but
would she be okay with it if we
commenting under somebody else's post no
would she be okay I think it works one
of two ways like you can't you can't
take one side just because one's a
female and then yeah back the other side
like true pick your own battles all all
the same but don't don't come at the man
for cheating if she's gonna put it out
there as if she's gonna cheat as well
well interesting that you say that well
I just think of it as like like mating
strategies like women want to get
attention from high status men that's
Instagram yeah well it's a big thing men
want to screw as many people as possible
so like how many I don't know anyone
that got married and closed their
Instagram I don't know anyone that did
it like my age anyway actually I told
you right so yeah so I'm saying modern
women are shitty why would you close
your Instagram I don't understand that
because it's advertised you're not
exercising
pull up pull this up I mean I I think it
really depends tell me that's not
advertising I mean she is
her job
you could argue Justin Bieber's job is
to screw groupies on tour yeah
the model what it's different he's not
he's not a model right so I do get what
you're saying it's a world famous pop
star
the world famous pop stars to do they
screw groupies on the tour bro this is a
Town's oldest time that's famous
yeah it is
that's Chris Brown do on state come on
this job yeah yeah and you know you can
just tell she would have none of that if
he was doing that yeah but it's like we
we're a society where men aren't told
they can do that they're controlling if
they tell a girl to close her Instagram
but women immediately want you to stop
sleeping with other girls and you can
tell like I know so many people in
relationships who've told people
unfollow her stop liking her photos I
know get rid of her if you do it to a
man or if you're in a relationship with
another guy and you tell her not to do
that you're the bad person well you've
got to be careful it goes one or two
like you have to look see I think that's
a standard respect thing
but if you're gonna do one way and not
accept it backwards yeah but there's
different hold on hold on this might be
controversial but I feel like there are
different
um
there are different reasons and there's
people with different circumstances for
example if there was if you was dating
someone and she was for example like a
content creator or something and she had
she was in you know Instagram engagement
groups so if she was an engagement group
in an engagement group There are rules
you have to like everyone's photo to
help each other with the algorithm right
so would you then turn around to your
girlfriend and say to her I don't want
you liking pictures of other guys the
standard person isn't honestly like I'm
not famous
I'm just saying would a good wife argue
with him when he asks that and say well
but my Instagram grouper would she just
say okay whatever you say honey yeah in
a really traditional setup she she would
give it up probably yeah you know if
she's making six figures well regardless
regardless of if he's making six figures
she should be like listen you know we're
married now that is I've made this
commitment in the in the eyes of the
Lord exactly and in the eyes of God so
that's more important to me than having
an Instagram
okay so I have a question why does he
have to be making six figures to have to
be listened to and do you have the same
energy if a woman's Med does she is she
if she's average looking does she not is
she not able to ask for loyalty
um that's a good question but you know
she's average looking so why does she
get to ask for that yeah
um
I don't know I don't I don't really know
how to answer that because I just feel
like
women do definitely look at Men's
financial status and we can sit here and
argue about that all the time but at the
end of the day there is survival and
women will always try to go with someone
above her level or at least on her level
she will never go low so you said six
figures
that's 10 a month no I know I was just
trying to be funny there but like
um no but I'm just saying like
realistically she will always go above
or on the same level so she's never
gonna go low so financial status does
get looked at and that is actually how
men earn respect from women I feel like
it's one of the ways that if you want to
earn respect from a woman you need to do
that you need to be able to bank yeah no
bro no brokies
how much does he have to make what about
an average guy
um I don't know I don't know what the
average salary here is what is it like
40 30 depends on your age so like 25
year olds can be earning like 35 000.
all right which in London isn't going to
be very much in in the standards of
learning six figures
and then it's on it's unfair to expect
that off someone
you've got the average you've got the
average UK wage though which is probably
like it's going to be weighted higher in
London yeah yeah because you've got
extremities you've got you know if
you're looking at the mean it's going to
be taking both these I mean does the man
expect us to be top 10 20 30 of beauty
no but why should they not if we're
expecting them to be in the highway I
think they do want that yeah they might
want it but they're not they're not
going to hold out for it because most
guys are quite thirsty do you know what
I mean we were talking about this the
other obviously the other night most
guys are quite thirsty
they're gonna take what they could get
you know oh oh yeah I mean that's a good
point it's a good point have you heard
the husband's store analogy no oh
there's like I hope I say this right
there's like a husband store analogy in
the manosphere okay and basically every
every store or every floor
is a different set of husbands okay and
you go up before
um then the only rules you can't go back
down so there's five floors total and
you you can go up but you can't go down
so the first floor is guys that love
kids
yeah and our and our loyal to you oh
that's sweet and so the women go to the
first floor so they go to the first
floor and they say you know what I want
more I wanna I wanna go up so they go to
the second floor and then they fight
they should do one no no no no it gets
better it gets better so these guys love
kids they're loyal and they're hot oh
yeah
well
next floor okay then they get just
curious yeah yeah so they go what's
what's next curiosity they say they say
okay the next floor these guys are hot
they make 70 000 a year they love kids
and they're loyal
but she's on the third floor and she's
like well what's what's happening what's
on the next floor and so back at it then
she goes next they make six figures
love kids loyal
everything but she wants to go to the
fifth floor and on the fifth
all the husbands are sold out
those dogs because die alone
a wife store right so on the first floor
there's women good sex loyal
sixes and they never found out was it
what was on the second floor
yeah good enough
I I think modern day women no offense
and I know I'm a woman but are super
like materialistic I don't agree
I love most of my friends but I know if
they were given the opportunity to go
with someone who aren't like over a
million they will take it they would
take it and they'll cheat on the person
that they love and they feel committed
to and they want and that's such an
issue well they cheat for money
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
but it's been normalized it's seen as
normal now to cheat and it seemed as
normal to like be like oh yeah but he's
better
why why not just fight three finally
better because he have money exactly why
is it why is that important
exactly and that's why guys shouldn't
get married because
that's the dynamic
but you're as a guy you're entering into
a contract with somebody when that is
the dynamic that's going on in society
and that's very problematic because
you're you're basically marrying into
it's like it's like buying a house that
it's got loads of faults with the house
and you're going to have loads of money
to pay further down the line it's like
you're buying you're getting into a
contract with somebody who is being
influenced by the society that's
basically saying to you there's always
going to be better there's always your
and not only is that always going to be
better but you deserve better you know
you go girl you go on to the next dude
like a mobile phone contract
like why is that worth it my Grandma had
13 kids for a fireman and she submitted
to him and that's that's the thing like
modern that's a good job but that's
beautiful that is what it should be it
was an average salary back then and so
I'm I'm just saying like you know what
is this generation this generation is
just getting worse but but money
shouldn't be the end
and it is what it is
if you feel that emotionally attached to
someone like if you're someone like me
that doesn't want to particularly get
married if you feel that emotionally
attached that you're willing to get
married you should not just up and leave
because someone else has more money or
someone else maybe is more attractive
like it should be all taken as I've
committed to this person for a reason
there was something there unless there's
something a lot deeper going on like
abuse or or something it's a lot deeper
and it's a lot more complex if it's
something as simple as that person earns
more I'm gonna go with them
so do you think that the woman so would
you say you think that the woman should
stick it out basically even if there is
like a period of suffering not
necessarily stick out but don't worry
say this man that she's with is like
literally not hardly making any money
they are really struggling like times
are really tough for her and do you
think that she should just stay and
stick it out or do you think she should
want better for herself
all right
um
I take you for my lawfully wedded
husband
right for better for worse for richer or
for poorer and sickness and health till
death do us part if you believe in
leaving the second there's a rough patch
you might get married
chip at that point oh that boy but
that's all Boomer stuff that Bible
but the whole point is like if if you
believe in divorce then why get married
there's no point just be in a
relationship because you're not a wife I
mean you you getting married and then
you think oh I'm gonna divorce one day
that's why they're on some prenups
though because it's like well I don't
think anyone wants to get divorced when
they get married they think it's forever
but I think things happen yeah and you
have to be realistic that but that's I'm
not saying that maybe you marry someone
and in the beginning it's all good and
then suddenly when you get married he
might lose his money and then leave him
no I don't agree with that but I feel
like yeah I feel like you should still
stay with that person but if there's no
progress there's no sign of him you know
working hard or trying we're trying to
get back to that level that he was at
before you know it's time to call it
quick this is what that's one more time
one more time
Better or For Worse for richer for
poorer yeah and sickness and in health
until death do us anyways that's it this
is what Massey the the author of the
rational male who talks a lot about this
kind of these kind of intergenerative
Dynamics he talks about the burden of
performance on men and that's exactly
what you're talking about then there's
always this there's this burden of
performance on men it's like okay well
he could have a rough patch but if he
doesn't shape up after two years you
know she's gonna be like thinking well
hang on what's going on which is
all right I understand why you would say
that but that is contrary to what Pearl
right now because the agreement is For
Better or Worse for sicker and poorer
because it could be he's got some
underlying issue like he's got maybe
some underlying like like depression or
something like that he's trying to deal
with some trauma and he's not working
he's not pushing himself to the degree
because of that but you know the the
woman who disregards that could just say
well solid you know I'm gonna go for
Steve over here because he's making six
figures so I have a question so the same
way you believe that
um if he's not making more money or
working or whatever you should leave
should he leave her if she gets fat
[Laughter]
I'm just asking yes
um
I think he's he's allowed to to bring it
up yeah for sure
we're gonna give her some chance you
know to get in the gym and she got like
three months six months oh well no
because she's not gonna leave him like
if the woman is like in that situation
she's not we're not saying the woman's
just gonna go right oh you're not
working for three months off I go like
it's not gonna happen like that she's
obviously gonna stick it out she's gonna
try and help especially if you've got
kids it's different like she may not be
able to go back to work they may have to
find alternative ways of surviving I
don't know it's very difficult but she's
not going to leave straight away it's
it's you know over a few years three
four years maybe I don't know
um
and in the same yeah same energy for for
the man as well if the woman's
completely let herself go and you know
she's not taking care of herself forget
a man it's not even good for you as a
woman forget him like it's about you
like you want to be able to look
yourself in the mirror and feel
confident and happy and you know
comfortable in your skin so go out and
do something about it so I yeah but he
have to make sure you you get like some
compliments about it you know so it can
make you feel better but are you going
to give them the same compliments if he
has no job oh yeah yeah you know what I
mean
you know I have a question do you
Journey I'm gonna help him do you
genuinely think most women nicely ask or
do you think most women nag let's just
yeah okay baby I'm so happy you didn't
do that thing I asked you to do last
week yeah very happy
the woman
could be away but the female condition
is very different to a man as well like
we we do like to
no offense but picket things yeah
whereas a mom will be very much more
upfront about it and if they have an
issue or something most of the time most
of the time not all men I I know not all
men are quite as straightforward as that
but most men will just say it as it is
whereas women will sugarcoat things and
kind of cannot be straightforward me it
makes it more complicated so if you
can't take it don't give it
my opinion on it is oh
um I actually haven't seen this response
video to me I was sent it so let's
um if you want to show the original Tick
Tock you know what okay I do want to can
you click my original Tick Tock I sent
Tick Tock a ride this week oh my gosh
all right
um what
oh yeah but you have to it's a stitch
you gotta click there
you see that yeah there you go
now
okay are you gonna
shove it
I'll look it I know I had something on
my shirt I'd like to say I'm in the car
thank you I don't know I don't know how
to curl my hair my friend does no have
you naturally straight hair no I just
that's the only thing I know
[Music]
okay wait go ahead
so I sent the internet a rye with this a
muck I've done that a lot this week okay
scroll it up uh we can't hear it
so a lot of the wives are triggered on
this app saying I'm young inexperienced
don't know what I'm talking about but I
listen to what the men say every single
day through consultations through what I
do for work YouTube videos made about
you guys don't shoot the messenger I'm
just letting you know a lot of you are a
shitty wives sorry okay this is the
wrong one I thought it was a different
one okay my the one I'm talking about
because I was responding to the other
one I just said okay look if you don't
clean you don't cook and you don't have
sex with him what does he get out of
that
that's a shitty wipe and you leave and
take half
[Laughter]
ouch
what does he get us the basic principle
of marriage
you're a shitty wife
okay if you could start if you get fat
oh God you're not loyal because you know
70 to 80 of women in the US are
overweight 78 yeah so yeah so so that's
one two we're not loyal we leave 70 to
80 percent of the time
on top of that
um one out of four marriages is sexless
so and I I can't imagine most women
really have their original recipes
really cater to men support them so it's
like okay I can't really say we're doing
a good job as a group I'm including
myself in this right but I'm just saying
as a group can we say we're we're
offering a lot
I feel like a lot of it comes down to
the fact that marriage is now
a nearly a political statement it's
nothing to do with the religion aspect
of it I'm not religious myself but I
come from a very religious background
I'm I'm born and raised in Northern
Ireland very religious and all the basis
of marriage is like the core elements of
it you hit religion out of that yeah
marriage is nothing but a statement yeah
she's right she's no you're right
because it's the because religion has
become you know watered down and fewer
people are religion religious today and
also societal constraints but the
societal constraints came out of
religion didn't they you know the whole
reason that it was so
um frowned upon for people to be
divorced and certainly for women to be
divorced in the past was because of the
religious aspects to it we'll take out
the religion and suddenly it's like well
what is the incentive do you know what I
mean there is no incentive and that's
that's the problem with the marriage
contract now
I also I think that's quite sad because
I feel like marriage has lost its
meaning like let's not forget marriage
is a beautiful thing it's a sacred thing
but that's only that's only if you're
religious that's the issue that that is
coming up at the minute I think they
come at that no but the marriage
but you'll figure
don't actually get that security the
type of security that you get when
you're married doesn't get sick because
Amanda doesn't get the security
certainly said the women leave I would
say yeah
it fault we don't get security okay we
wanted to work we said send us to work
and then we go to work and now the wages
are cut in half for everyone when you
got double the amount of employees it's
our own fault and then women women who's
in charge of sex right so women said you
know I used to require marriage to have
sex with me now we don't do that so as
far as our own fault
broke down because of women
[Music]
I'll tell you I'll tell you this my
grandma my grandma
old lady sweet lady she had nine kids my
dad had 13 my mom had I got a lot big
family right and you know she's getting
older right and I asked her
um like Grandma why do you think like
the divorce rate spiked so much because
the divorce rate really went um up in
the 60s right and I was like Grandma
like what like why is that like what
what happened you were around right
she looks at me she says birth control
made him do it
oh okay
there's no about stats but if you
let the birth control rate and the
divorce rate they're the same
so what are you saying that the birth
control does something to the women kind
of thing now I think women just wanted
to sleep around oh yeah lovely
um
to have a difference in your
yeah because I've had attractiveness
basically is just what you're attracted
to at the time when you're a hormonal
yeah I heard that I've heard stories
there's some really interesting research
I'm very scientific I I study science as
a degree some really interesting
research on it but it still doesn't give
to a reason have you heard about women
who get married to a dude when they're
on birth control and they come off
that's not a materialistic thing though
at least at least it's just it's
something a bit deeper there isn't it do
you know why that is is that because
when she's on the birth control she's
looking for a certain type of dude it's
a completely different hormonal
imbalance in the body so when you come
off the birth control is it different
hormones is it basically when she's on
birth control she's looking for a more
of a dad kind of character then she
comes off it she's looking for life I
think it's a personal preferences
you were right because I thought it was
because this isn't when you're on birth
control like the body tricks you into
and you're looking for those aspects
like a strong man man with good
selective genes good and what you want I
thought you wanted the resources because
you already got you but that that's the
you when you feel that you're pregnant
you want that security but then when you
come off it it's just go wild in
it I mean that's the energy though in it
they come off it and they're like
they want they're more they're more up
for yeah yeah any anything because
there's an idea there's I don't know if
you guys agree with this or not but
there's an idea in the men's online you
know advice space that basically women
look for two different things they look
for the dads and they look for the cats
so they look for the guys who are more
like the provider guys more he's a nice
guy he's Dependable he's solid he's got
a good pension pension planning place
you know all that stuff and then you've
got the sexy the sexy dude over here who
maybe hasn't got any of that stuff but
he's ripped to these like Devil May care
and he's like he does you know he's that
kind of and and there's this idea that
women look for those two things the way
it sounds like you're saying is that all
the birth control they go for the first
and then they come with the birth
control they're like right where's Chad
yeah
these days men wants kids more than
woman wants kids no I don't know I think
it's I um
I think today's society though is not
more about what the man or woman wants
it's more about what's being pushed on
you yeah so a lot of people are thinking
I don't want too many children because
the financial aspect of it or I don't
want too many children because the
environmental aspects of it or it's just
personal preference
yeah exactly and there's a huge amount
of evidence now saying if you're into
your 40s and you're having a child you
increase the risk of them having severe
other problems abnormalities having Down
syndrome and as much as those children
they thrive in life but it's not fair to
push that on them knowing you're you're
going into your 40s and you're having a
child I mean I I don't I don't agree
with it it's not fair when she was 45
not it's not everyone it's not everyone
but the science the science supports it
saying once you reach a certain point
you increase that risk of something like
that happening or still births or having
a child that has fear fatal fatal and
which then into their very very young
years end up dying so I think that's a
lot of the things that now because we
have the research back and up people are
going well it's too late and I don't
wanna I don't want to force that on a
child which is fair which is fair with
both sides man and woman I think it's
both works both ways what age is it over
for a woman
what age is it like it's you're not
gonna be a wife
but it depends about kids let's talk
about okay let me I'm just gonna clarify
a little bit we're not going to talk
about the exceptions I know somebody
yeah there's always going to be
acceptable right there's always going to
be so I heard a lady gave birth at 60.
oh yeah but nothing knowing knowing that
men today are more hesitant to get
married right and half of they're
predicting half of women in our age
group aren't even going to be married
they're you know 50 of us in the room
never married no kids that's what
they're predicting okay at what age
is it would you say over you know that
probably No One's Gonna Marry You no
one's if no one's trying if no one's
tried if no one's tried to marry you yet
you're probably never gonna get it oh
what age what do you think
um as a woman
um what age would you say when you're a
spinster like no offense like for late
late 40s 45 late over okay kind of yeah
when do you think it's over oh yeah I'd
say probably 45 and over yes okay 45
same yeah 40. I'm gonna come back to you
45.
I think because a lot of people because
people who are getting married tend to
want families doesn't it so they're
going to look at them and go what if I
might love you but I yeah but in
traditional aspects marriages to support
a family and they might look at it and
go we're most likely not going to have a
child so I mean if I'm not religious is
there any point get married at this
point that's why I said I didn't say
relationship marriage all right Trey
what do you think what age uh 27. 27.
I knew that would trigger though I knew
that would trigger everyone I just like
the precisiveness
um in all seriously so if we're talking
about having kids though as well like
not just are we talking marriage and
kids this is just personally I feel like
most guys over a certain age they'll get
in a long-term relationship with a girl
but why get married if they're kids yeah
no true true at what age is it would you
say as a guy you're like couldn't start
a family with her you can have it to me
but if you don't have kids so if she if
you had a girl you really liked right
and you were thinking of someone you
wanted to start a family with but you
said you know what too old I mean to be
honest I think it's going to be like
mid-30s probably yeah yeah realistically
because of the things you're talking
about as well because you start to think
getting much older than that you start
thinking well you know would everything
be be okay you know
um
yeah
because if you think about it what a
women's Peak fertility use really it's
like 22 23 right yeah yeah yeah just
under 25 I think yeah to start reaching
30 that's when it starts we're getting
quite dangerous yeah 90 of your eggs are
gone by 30. yeah wow
crazy that's why marriage used to be so
much younger that's why people used to
get married a lot younger but now now a
lot of people don't want to have
children so they get married a lot later
because it's yeah I mean you could
definitely if it's just if it's just
marriage for like companionship then to
be fair people could get married older
you know like you might meet somebody
you know in the nursing home and you're
just like all right
on the death bed oh my God I need to
spend this money
I noticed are you engaged I saw the I
see that me no I always get asked this
no this is um on the right hand not on
the left hand okay no everyone always
asks me that no not yet soon maybe
hopefully oh funny we pray
um okay next question next question
because I feel like I was given so much
Flack for this are you a good wife if
you get married and then you gain 100
pounds is that good wife
I'm just I'm just asking am I off base I
mean was there a reason for that like
it's so impossible it doesn't matter the
reason I mean you're not a bad wife for
gaining a hundred pounds
so like okay let me let me just say so I
lost my job and refused to work as a
husband but I did it for a reason
am I a good husband
you know I lost my job but I was
depressed I mean I think that happened
it could be on benefit yeah I didn't say
I didn't say that it doesn't happen I
didn't say you couldn't work through it
I just said good good means like a good
A B student right that's good um I don't
know I kind of need specifics because
like gaining weight and being depressed
obviously you can gain weight as a girl
because you're depressed
so so you know I got married I'm in love
I'm just gonna eat Krispy Kremes every
day if if you're not willing to look out
for your own health though yeah yeah
no I don't I don't think it is so my
question good wife or bad wife
see I don't think it's I don't think
it's quite a straightforward but in it
I have a question you have to pick one
you gotta pick good or bad I have a
question I I would say if I'm still
looking after him and doing all the
things that a wife should do but yeah I
just gained a few pounds or whatever I
said 100. yeah what still looking after
him he can't say nothing I'm still a
good wife
all right I'm gonna get the same person
like does it change it look at Piers
brosman is that his name who's that his
wife the old James Bond his wife was
stunning when they were young and now if
you look at her she's gained a lot of
weight and he told them he was like I
didn't fall in love with her because of
the way she looked he was like I fell in
love with her soul yeah yeah I think
that sounds like I don't know why men
cap he would not have approached her
come on
they sell us this fairy tale you know
I'm not saying that she can't provide
other things but that action all right
can we just sorry that action is that a
good wife I didn't talk about her
cooking
as well like if you don't care and
there's no backline issue to why you've
done that no it's a bad way yeah it's a
because if you don't care and you've
gone you should love me the way I am if
that's how it was in the beginning then
that's why maybe I'm coming across a bit
strong did you say she was oh she was
real who said they're real she's the
realest so far
okay okay next one on my list all right
if you refuse to have sex with your
husband good wife or bad wife bad okay
thank you thank you good night for bad
refuse yeah
I need contacts yeah like I have no idea
what that means I think in a
stereotypical sense because normally
when a woman refuses is because there's
an emotional disconnect or there's
something that's seriously going wrong
then should you still use should you
still be married then or should you have
gotten married and satisfied woman I
mean no but I mean
I have a question do good wives put
their feelings above what's best for the
family
yeah oh it's me well I don't I don't
feel right so let me just not sleep with
my husband because of the way I feel is
that a good wife my feelings before
everybody else's I mean as long as
you've expressed that to your partner
and he's okay with that no I don't have
to be open I just wanna I just don't
have a question I'm just just yeah
do you think most men would be okay with
having a wife that does not have sex
with them no no okay no I think you'd be
a problem okay yeah it won't be
problematic okay because you guys were
like well maybe if I explain to him why
I'm not is there a reason they could
give you you're like
you just not have sex I think that would
be robbing salt into the womb to be
honest I think that might make it worse
if she's trying to justify it it's like
because the problem is what the guy's
giving you is his commitment he's giving
you his commitment I'm not going to
sleep with anyone else and then he's and
then if you're also not having sex with
him then obviously that's going to leave
him in a deficit yeah but there's
obviously a reason for it but it depends
it really has to depend what that reads
for example if she's with like an
abusive man that's a completely that's
one of those extremities
why do we keep going to the extreme when
we're talking about the norm
I think she's looking at staring women
only reviews the intimacy if there is a
problem
I say that because women use it
sometimes as a weapon we do yeah yeah I
don't think that's okay yeah that's not
okay but she's probably using it as a
weapon because there is a valid reason
but could she be not willing to be
intimate with him because just because
the butterflies are gone just because
she's
yeah why do we keep adding things to
avoid the actual question is not sleepy
if you're a good wife if you refuse to
sleep with your husband that is the
question it's not if you're an abusive
it's just are you a good wife if you
won't have sex with your husband without
the extremities I think is what she's
trying to say okay that's so confusing
to me because I'm trying to put my mind
I'll tell you so I have a friend he's a
20-year divorce attorney he says it's
very common that women get the two kids
they want and they just stop sleeping
with the husband they got what they want
okay no that's wrong
and a lot of times it's not for a really
good reason well we have Stu like it
depends where we are in our cycle we're
crazy
I'm mad at your boyfriend for something
stupid yes all the time and like every
day you don't think good wives know that
you know we can be crazy we can be
emotional so we put the family before us
feelings
yeah yeah yeah anyone disagree with that
no okay
okay so good wives have sex even when
they don't want to yes or no I think
that's a connection
yeah yeah sure yes
yes she doesn't she's fighting it
it's hard because I don't agree with it
so yeah I'll say yeah yeah whatever you
guys the same
yeah but but I I it depends on what kind
of of time of frame you're like time
frame that you're talking about if you
just mean in general yeah
there should even if you're not feeling
totally up to it but you haven't had it
in a while it's a respect thing like
you're married to them give like I would
want the same from them so yeah back and
forth in it but if there was some
underlying I know
Irish when I leave at a London slang I
love that but yeah yeah I think if if
it's uh just you know it's a back and
forth in it like you have to do it again
another question okay how many meals if
we're talking a student the best wives
how many meals should a good wife cook
for her husband a day
a good a student
no how many
one no that's an A okay what about you
one one that's an a student okay I'm
gonna say two that's okay that's an A A
okay
how many meals yeah how many meals
there's three minutes lunch and dinner
yeah how many meals and snacks
first
oh yeah breakfast sometimes
um
uh I'm gonna say one and a half like
you do the prep who does the coke yeah
all right what about you
um I quite like cooking so I do three
three Good Wife okay don't what would
you say that a good husband pays a
hundred percent of the bills a plus
husband
no no a plus like like this is the the
ideal like again we're always I'm
talking I do ideal
I don't think you should pay for
everything okay I think his money is our
money my money is my money
thank you high five oh no I'm sorry but
I found to do it that's weird Okay do
good wives look at their money as the
family money or is their own money
the a plus wives family family yeah
like you don't think that's a selfish
mentality that is yeah it is
oh my God yeah so like um if my husband
has money and I have money like it's for
the family okay basically if I've
answered and you you high-fived her why
why
um
because I kind of agree with that like
yeah like my money is my money
he knows that I can do what I want with
that obviously because I'm a good wife I
am going to invest that in it yeah I'm
gonna I'm not gonna spend it I'm
probably gonna invest it in my kids I'll
maybe have like 20 for me to go get my
hairs done
of course
in return he gets one meal a day
he gets one meal a day all right he gets
two he gets lunch and dinner but
breakfast is off the cards I wake up
late
so would you spoil him would you spoil
your mum yeah because you said that your
money is your own so would you just
spend with yourself or would you no I'm
gonna spare my mom spoil my mind what do
you mean like especially with your
lunches
no you see something that he really
likes you're like you know what I'm
gonna get this woman yeah yeah with mine
are you gonna are you gonna buy him
let's say what's an expensive watch
bro listen no honestly if I'm making
that type of money I will buy him his
favorite one yeah okay now another
question do good wives give up their
careers for their children
I think yes yes
remember this is I'm not saying
everyone's got to be an a student and
everything no no I don't give up your
careers no oh good good wives should go
to work instead of spend time with their
kids no for a certain amount of time
yeah you know I get it you know staying
home with your kid but definitely going
back I believe I mean so I'm talking
about when push comes to shut your kids
need you yeah so if you're gonna have
children they should always come first
regardless whether a man or a woman yeah
I totally I mean yeah yeah okay this is
this is the problem with Society at the
minute this is the problem with Society
now no but it is that they have children
and they focus on Career if you want to
have a child you're gonna have to
sacrifice whether you're a man or a
woman you have to sacrifice
so many children so many children are
emotionally neglected because they're
passed off to to Nanny
yeah and if you're willing to have a
child you need to have a financial
support to be able to go I'm going to
take a step back I'm not going to quit
work you don't have to quit it just take
a step back to be able to go this child
needs me emotionally for the next 17
years of its life you know what I mean
Rich
the gestation period of humans is much
longer good good wives are happy to give
up their careers to spend more time with
their children yes okay yeah okay yes
you agree yes yeah okay why aren't you
why wouldn't you be to give up here like
I'm just curious like why why wouldn't
you want to give up your career for a
kid I mean of course I would like in the
beginning they're growing up I have to
be there
um but I don't believe in like
completely cutting off your career just
because of your kid of course you love
your child that is you get that's you
you gave birth to that child I
understand that but completely
neglecting your career something that
you've like worked for maybe you've gone
to University
um you know you've you're driven in this
you love it and you've given it up I
just don't believe in that why
and you wanted this family right yeah
most of the time you can come back to it
though yeah but not for 17 years I'm not
going to take a break
I never say it I never say just drop
okay you shouldn't you don't think good
wives would want to like good wives if
they could take 17 18 years off to raise
the kids what's so good about I mean a
lot of jobs anyway to be honest I mean
what's so good about like we're the only
species on the planet that work and pay
to live on the earth if you're gonna
raise something that's so natural you
should be willing to drop some of that
materialistic aspect if you have the
support surrounding it but I think it
works both for a man and a woman I don't
think you should if if you're a single
dad you should and you have the
financial support there you should
definitely want to spend more time with
your child and maybe put your career as
a second second best yeah I'll be surely
what is the ultimate purpose that we're
on this planet it's it's other people
isn't it it's children it's fast it's
family it's all of those things right I
mean
why is any of us why is any of us men or
women why are we saying oh just going
and work in a cubicle is more important
than that
um you know I have another statement
okay
good wives don't leave no matter what
I didn't do something outside let me let
me I'll give you please don't say abuse
please I will give you this I will give
you abuse but good you know what
good wives believe in separations they
don't believe in divorce
um
what do you say separation do you mean
do you mean legally separated basically
living in the same house we're not being
married
I had that growing up I grown up with my
parents and I I know that's normal to me
actually no I have to say that's more
painful
they got divorced for me it was as a
child it was so much
you don't legally yeah but I I'm saying
I think but you live separate in two
different houses so that's basically the
same no sometimes you live in the house
yeah that's how we were we lived in the
house that's what happened to me
so tell me your thoughts do good wives
leave yes or no and good wives only
believe in separation they don't believe
in divorce
what do you think tell me why here
um I mean if you want to leave leave
honestly it doesn't make you a bad
person I just just leave like if
I don't know it can be really at all
this or you're just not feeling anymore
like both of you it's a mutual thing or
okay just leave I don't believe in that
separation so a good wife can leave
okay go ahead
uh yeah I do agree with you
um only because based of my personal
experience and watching my parents be
like that I always grew up wanting them
to actually get a divorce because it was
so damaging to us as children
so I feel like
life is way too short to stay in a
marriage with someone that you are not
happy with and to continue living a
miserable life yeah why why put yourself
through that why put your kids through
that as well if kids are involved as
well so I do think you can still be a
good wife but you can also leave maybe
do it for the kids yeah like well
because kids have better outcomes yeah
I'm saying stay together for the kids no
I don't like no that's even worse no no
yeah but see I as I was the kid and I
always wanted my parents to get a
divorce I would even tell them why don't
you guys get a divorce because it was so
painful seeing them be the way they were
with each other living that separated
life in the same house but how do you
how do you know it would have been a
better outcome for you you seem to have
turned out okay
right thank you
um you're out with the parents doesn't
necessarily indicate what's going on in
the inside though yeah exactly but I'm
saying I've been here like I don't know
um
every statistic statistic will tell you
it's better to have two parents in the
same house than it is yeah but one
person
I know but then that kid also has to
deal with that trauma for example I have
trauma now growing up you may see me
like this but like you don't know how I
am inside like I have childhood trauma
now because of my parents marriage and
witnessing what went on in that house
because they did not uh get a divorce
did they not get along they would fight
a lot yeah absolutely they did not get
along and really and truly they should
have got divorced but because of the
kids they stayed and because my mum
believed in this whole I need to be a
good wife and I can't leave him now that
he's old and throw him out she stayed
but I wish she would have got divorced
because that was really painful as a
child growing up to see those things
what if one of them had moved out though
and you hadn't seen them as much would
that have been painful as well do you
think I think either way it would that
either way it would have been but I
actually would have preferred but if
they had got a different house yeah I
would have liked my dad my dad's not
alive anymore
um but I would have liked it if he moved
out and we saw him on weekends or
something because I feel like it would
have been a healthier environment for us
kids I think it causes a divide and a
toxic household as well it was an
extremely toxic household it was and it
was really hard growing up dealing with
that actually
um and it's also given me trauma now
that you know I'm in a relationship and
I'm planning to get married and I worry
that I'm gonna have the same life my mum
and dad had which is a horrible feeling
but that is what kids who go through
those things end up feeling when they
get to my age do you think that's me do
you look at
kind of marriage as a more kind of
solid thing now though you look at it
and you go I have to want this so badly
yeah before I get it it's like I want to
break the generational curse now because
because it's a lot of women in my family
unfortunately left their husbands
um that's that at least that's a
positive outlook that you've got on it
you can look at it and be like yeah I
want to be successful that's yeah that's
strong and can hold together even
through hardship you can be like yeah I
don't want what happened before yeah
they said something you can kind of yeah
have you ever seen a healthy
relationship no I don't have a
representation of a healthy relationship
no so how how would you learn how to be
a wife
um I'm doing a lot of inner work like
I'm really searching inwards I
you know I've looked into therapy I I've
tried to work on myself I tried to work
on my traumas I really want to break
that generational curse
um so I have healthy open com you know
conversations with my mum about these
things in the past and her marriage with
my Dad we talk about these things on a
daily basis
um so I feel like I I have
I have the right mindset now because I
know what I don't want and I don't want
that unhealthy toxic environment that
unfortunately I grew up in as a child I
don't want my kids to go through that so
I feel like all the things that my mum
and dad went through I don't want to be
reenacting those in my marriage
um when it goes back to what you just
asked
um I agree with you
um I don't have any parents in my life
mom or dad
um I had a mom who played a woman and a
father
um but I think when it comes to
relationships and what you choose I
think it comes to choices and what you
learn I think the world I think that's
quite big to be honest but I think just
like learning from people around you you
just kind of sit back and be like do I
like that do I accept that
um and I think it's just Choice really
what makes you happy and you just build
yourself if that makes sense like with
me I think Love's beautiful I would like
I love that yeah I would love to get
married and it's not just marriage you
know I understand where you're coming
from it's like signing a paper and I get
where you where like you come from I
understand that but I feel like
there's someone out there for everyone I
agree you know yeah and I want yeah I
agree with you and I think I would love
to get that opportunity maybe another
country why did you think that that why
because what was that I didn't even hear
it there's not there's not someone for
everyone
why yeah because some women die alone a
lot of women do they do all the time
some men die alone but how'd you know
they didn't have the love of their life
yeah oh and they lost it yeah because
one out of three manners because
[Laughter]
there's more women than men on the
planet so if every woman had someone
there would be eat 50 50. but there's
also yeah
there are people like me there's a good
question do you see yourself sorry a bit
topic but I'm just quite curious would
you do you see yourself marrying a man
or not like again I would only ever get
married if that other person really
wanted it but I I've actually this is
probably the first time that I've ever
openly come out let's play sexual
oh
I mean I yeah either way if if it meant
a lot to the other person and I
you know felt like it I was in a
possession in my life to be like does
that means so much to you I want to be
able to give that to you would you marry
a woman yeah yeah
but I I again it wouldn't be because I
want even with the nagging
who here thinks I just want to raise a
hand who thinks good wives don't leave
you do everyone else thinks good wives
leave oh actually wait no good wives
will never leave good good wives you
think that I don't think you're no
you're not a wife if you leave I think
if you sign up for something
what do you mean you're not you're no
longer a wife if you leave are you
you're no longer so you're neither are
someone else's wife yeah but you're no
and not situation you're no longer the
wife to be a good wife I'm just gonna I
just kind of want to break this down
okay this is why men are complaining
it's like they maybe get one meal from a
good wife and she's she's okay to leave
if she feels like it and we fight I mean
he's okay to leave as well like it's a
two-way station
but the thing is we don't have anything
on the line if a man marries you you I'm
doing a documentary on the court system
here you you literally are paid like
lawyers
um
you are you get a free Council here if
you say that he abused you and you can
deny him access for his kids up to two
years trying to get like he doesn't have
a chance in court vice versa no it's not
Vice no no but vice versa it's so much
harsher on the man there's no no it's so
it's so much harsher on the man to the
point ninety percent of the time um
women get custody yeah and it's actually
like it's actually a really it's really
sad I'm interviewing some of the guys
that have like been through it it's
there are guys that haven't seen their
kid in four years because they're exacus
them of abuse and they never did it and
there's no proof there's no don't you
know they didn't do it though because
there's no proof that doesn't mean
anything that doesn't it doesn't mean
that they do something or okay you think
it's do you think it's okay to deny
access to children with no evidence of a
crime
no evidence they never press charges no
evidence I think it very much we should
just take take women's word amber
heard's word
that's another that's another thing
so it's like what are guys getting out
of this um
is it just um is it just what do you say
abuse is it is it also like mental
coercion as well because and they're
expanding that's what they're doing
they're expanding the definition of
abusive if a girl says oh I want to buy
two thousand dollars worth of addresses
and he says that now that he can put
that under like mental Financial
coercion or something or if he said if
he said oh stop following guys on
Instagram or something like that could
be seen as manipulation yeah it's really
scary the more there's this one story
where the woman
um accused him of of touching the kids
and remember and remember remember
they're financially incentivized to do
that and then what they can do is they
go to Family Court and in family court
you don't actually have a jury to judge
you of your peers which you should be
entitled to and so they can go to Family
Court and deny you access to your kids
until they actually
um finished yeah and that can take up to
two years so if he has a newborn he
won't see the kid for two years and she
has no punishment if she lied like this
is what Manner this is what men have to
deal with here and it's like well if she
lied honestly I feel like she should
have punishment that that should be but
you know what happened to him he killed
himself oh wow but they but they women
do get punished for for example like I
don't really know but it's like she
accuses the man of like not in family
sexually assaulting no they don't and
family I'm telling you I've interviewed
the guys that they don't it's really sad
and so it's like the guys are like well
what do we get out of this and we can't
even like admit we can't even say what's
a good wife what's a bad wife
because everyone has their own
experience experiences their own
interpretations yeah but we know vaguely
what's a good husband what's a bad
husband a husband you wouldn't want a
husband that like doesn't protect you
that if someone tries to beat you up
he's like oh go do it yourself babe
we could say in generalities that women
like men want thin wives in general I
mean maybe slim thick
they're allowed to say that if they want
to say that they can say that right but
I'm saying we can't even say it they
can't even get three meals out of us for
a good remember I kept saying an A plus
student except except you
she she gives three meals
I like cooking so it's like there we go
you've got to like doing something
haven't you to be like it's like the gym
isn't it you've got to enjoy it no
actually no I mean I work at it so I
have to
I'm trying I'm trying with the gym shout
out to my boxing coach
I'm trying to remember I'm watching this
like good yeah sorry thank you all right
I'm gonna Read Super chats really quick
um also guys make sure you like the
video and let me know in the comments
what do you guys think Good Wife bad
wife what what do you think
um makes a good wife okay see Dumbledore
half of the girls over 30 are single and
childless the percent is rising every
year of the six girls on the show at
least three of you will die alone
I hope at this point I hope uh black
Moses Pearl stop being soft with these
women uh Manny F so Michelle Obama
should have left Barack Obama because
she hated him for 10 years out of their
30 years together follow me stop blaming
them and get counseling uh Scott and
Bradley a shout out to top producer a
shout out blessing
[Music]
uh black Moses um they can't answer
simple questions and they keep talking
about the exceptions women like them are
the reason guys get passwords fellas
invest in cat food and box wine um
battery buddies Logan his money is our
money my money is my money this is why
we don't care about your career or your
education ladies we don't get the
benefit at all we still need to earn
you'll notice no men are lining up to
date Oprah follow me you can still work
on your education which is more
important not your career a scouting
Bradley to a good man his wife and his
kids come first always brownie to the
panel do women now focus on imaginary
patriarchy just to distract themselves
from the fact they no longer know how to
be matriarchs stop adding things to
avoid the actual questions good God see
Dumbledore If a married woman losing
weight is an absolute guarantee that
she's either going to cheat leave or
both 100 correlated it's as bad as if
she's making more money than her husband
the female wedding vows I love you until
I find someone better or I earn more
than you
uh Pearl you're looking healthier these
days more meat John Quinn um
John Quinn hi Pearl your hair in your
outfit look great I don't know what
you're doing but keep it up the XY ghost
uh Pearl you're too soft on these women
on your shows you ask them how much
money does a man need to make you love
him and many success how many successful
relationships have you had I am I'm
talking about divorce if the kids did it
lives didn't matter Scott Bradley most
women do not know that marriage is bad
until the women leaves midnight Shepherd
break it off if a girl gets fat
absolutely not you should be with that
person I want to marry them just because
you're not compatible just like money
just like money should not be an issue
if a man's misleading you dick Maximus a
man smashed 11 women by pretending to be
an agent of a sugar daddy who needed him
to test the ladies out before me
um Armstrong's pearly
um uh the clue Channel hit the like ribs
just a wife you mean the position most
women strive to get to having the
opportunity to raise your kids correctly
in such a corrupt Society full of agenda
is priceless please come correct
um
Trevor do they think that makeup would
Define a woman d c a and DC hi Pearl I'm
looking or a pleasure to meet you at
your London media Meetup looking forward
to the next one see Dumbledore if I've
improved Myself by gluing my eyelids
anti-aircraft fake lashes that would
make the Ukrainian Army blush Hinesburg
if he's hot and smart and wants Mrs nine
Nails um Zoros lost women 30 plus and
single moms are recreational use only
black Moses these women are allergic to
accountability modern women always blame
someone else instead of looking in the
mirror ribs women could control access
to sex if so if men want to have sex
they have to appease women to have sex
equality is if a woman wants a
relationship then she has to appease the
man
towel on 92.65 if you're in control of
something you dictate how it's used
simple as raise your standards for
giving it up and it fixes the problem
not rocket science Hinesburg evil lady
stop projecting your agenda you want to
be hunted no man wants to no men want to
hunt women we have better things to do
with our lives than validate you see
Dumbledore girl in the back for a girl
in the back um if only 10 the only
for the oh and I've read these are these
from the last show oh I think they
are the thumbnails look so similar now
blessing
um okay let's see Nathan Arbor
um the lady who's getting married who is
getting married is a future divorce uh C
Dumbledore half of these girls okay I
read these okay
um I now want to play
I don't know which one I want to do I
want to do the hater video or do I want
to do the other one
uh Let's do let's do the the social
media one the last one I sent you
not the one from the Google Doc the one
I emailed you
so I was scrolling through social media
and there's a story that's viral this
week
so
um I forgot the guy's name
what's his name
what
Tyrese Tire what's his last name
Tyrese Gibson Tyrese Gibson did you guys
see the story with Tyrese Gibson so he
was a guy in Fast and Furious
okay oh yeah friends with um Paul Walker
yeah so what is he bold yes
him and his girl he has a girlfriend
now we can decide as a group is she wife
material just based on this clip you
know I know we don't we don't have to
say that we don't know all the facts you
know just based on this clip wife
material or not wife material
DMS yeah we Linked UP
he wasn't my type at all
what type is actually Paul Walker
recipes oh my gosh but I
it wasn't my type at all and nighttime
is not white I'm just saying I was more
interested in touch
don't touch me
um
and
even when I met him I was like um he's
kind of old uh
I just like his smile it's pretty cool
there's just one this one his
personality his personality his ships
went really bad really fast his
personality was okay but I'm getting off
live he didn't understand the Instagram
model
um thing so he would always talk down so
you wanted the homie you didn't want me
it's cuter yeah
I'm old you know all this already I
wasn't here type either so relax
and um yeah so now we're here it's like
an actual somewhat of a love story which
is crazy because I didn't know that I um
yeah no I'm done no no don't trust me
don't put up this kid
okay what's your initial reaction to
that that's so wrong I'm so shocked Is
that real then that was hard who they
weren't like pretending or anything
who knows okay
who is wrong
he was quite clearly uncomfortable and
she kept going with it and kept touching
him when he said stop touching me yeah
the other way around it was awkward
pretty awkward to watch wasn't it yeah
it was horrible I was cringing but also
he looked so embarrassed as well yeah I
was about it for him can you imagine can
you imagine if the rules were reversed
and he said you know she was kind of
chubby not really my type I wanted her
friend
that would have gone down so horribly
yeah it shouldn't go either way neither
person should ever say that to either
person but yeah it would be it would be
in the eyes of society yeah yeah and
that shouldn't be how it's adapted
that's wrongful so she got a guy that's
hot okay let's just let's just be real
here man gorgeous gorgeous
and Rich allegedly he said he was
faithful in his life in his last
marriage right so I mean who knows
celebrities right you know
Instagram and saying she wanted his
friend yeah that was so by the way
that was the worst part that was and the
fact that she went r.i.b no oh yeah that
was I missed so disrespectful on so many
different levels yeah and the whole
Instagram model comment it's so cringe
yeah it was trying to flip it though
wasn't it I don't know what she was
talking she was trying to Flap it she
was trying to flip my name and then yeah
yeah she was like oh yeah but you said
this yeah it was just trying to flip it
round on him to make him look like that
he was not having it it was so
uncomfortable it was horrible what was
your question about were you what you
just said to ask us
oh who was wrong yeah yeah
um yeah yeah she's definitely in the
wrong there's there's yeah 100 that's
right it's just not okay why do we live
in a society where women think they can
put their men down on social media
so I think it's
have you have you ever heard a girl say
oh he you know he's he's just an idiot
or he's maybe not he's seen it yeah I've
seen it yeah
yeah well there's been this thing hasn't
there for a long time where guys on me
in the media like say Homer Simpson guys
on adverts guys in sitcoms are shown to
be the idiot you know the do first like
the fat husband who's useless and blah
blah blah and it's almost like a sort of
a meme Now isn't it where women it's
acceptable for women to say that kind of
thing but if a guy said something
similar to a woman that would be
completely yeah yeah I think because
women are meant to be the mature ones
you know that's the that's the narrow
narrative and it's like no a woman can
be goofy she can be a bit immature as
well and the guy could be mature than
her but we don't see that much if that
makes sense because like you said we
always seen the media that the guy's a
bit stupid and the woman's always like
yeah kind of yeah she's always there
like lecturing him or being like do this
do that and yeah it's just become
acceptable that way around hasn't it in
western culture for some reason I don't
think I don't agree with it it's not
good I don't think you should put your
man down I think that actually makes you
you look bad and I think it says more
about you and your character what she's
saying and she's like yeah yeah I
thought your mate was hotter but you
know I kind of settled for you I mean
yeah she's basically saying like I
didn't even really want you in the first
place I've just I'm just here I wonder
if your friend but your friend don't
want me
yeah and he's dead as well which is
awful it's just degrading I didn't like
that yeah it just that's awful I feel
like it's extreme feminist so that I've
turned that kind of narrative where
they've got we can say what we want I
think it's just because we're females
but um really you neither person can say
what they want you have to have
regardless of what gender you are you
have to mutual respect yeah the
feminists have flipped that and they've
gone because they don't want they don't
want equality
I'm not I I'm I'm equality everyone
should be equal but in retrospect so you
should only you it's like saying a
goldfish should do the same test as a
bear like a goldfish can't climb a tree
you know what I mean it it doesn't being
equal doesn't necessarily mean that
you're gonna do the same things or be
able to be tested on the same things but
feminists they want to switch the whole
narrative I think men and women can't
ever be equal because we're not I agree
no but biologically we're totally
different totally different when they
say are we want equality it's like what
does equality look like you want to do
half of the Brick Lane half of the
plumbing half of the electric yeah
no they're doing loads of sewage
rebuilding aren't they in London at the
moment so maybe women could get on board
with that
I used to work in construction the
majority of the employees are men it's
like it's a majority it's like I think
it's 98 then in all those fields yeah
the women usually take on the admin
roles it's not usually the hard labor
which they're they're more most of them
are more than able to do it but they
don't want to I quite like that which is
where feminism comes from yeah
um
I quite like that woman can have this
Independence
in a way but then I kind of but like I
still agree with
you know being that wife and staying at
home the housewife but personally to to
some extent I like to work as well
and obviously and
money and realistically the man is
always going to be making more
you know and I'm not on about like
job-wise or anything because it is equal
I'm on about you know like I've said
before like
um when I do have kids I won't be
working he'll be working
you know so
the other thing
um would you guys submit to a guy in a
50 50 relationship
so what he says goes
you're not going out tonight
if it's 50 50 yeah no sacrifice
but then there's submission submission
isn't sacrificed I'm not so it's not
it's not even that it's just I feel like
I'm a wife you know what I mean so I'm
I'm gonna do what he says but the
respect isn't always going to be there
for him because it's just 50 50. why are
you asking me to bring 50 like you're
telling me you're not capable
of you know you need my help basically
and that's not attractive to women when
men say that here we go it's the burden
of performance again isn't it the guys
being real as a woman when a guy says
like oh I need you to help me with this
it's a bit like
the one thing that was in the long run
most women are going to want to work the
same when they're older yeah so it's
like okay you know let's just say you're
in your 30s you're single right we're
not bringing the same youth infertility
that we used to bring so how can we
expect them to take over 100 of the
bills and and it's like okay the next
you're gonna be with him the next 50
years maybe you only work the next 20
and 30.
but he's probably going to work longer
than you
yeah
but I just I just thought it was the
question sorry the would you submit if
it's 50 50.
I don't think I would I don't but submit
as in like do what he says or so Matt is
like a boss
okay so when you go to work right I
don't know what you do for work on if
you work for yourself but you've had a
boss at some point or I think of it like
a coach right I pick which coach I want
right so and what he says goes I have to
listen to him at the end of the day you
know I might make a case occasionally
but you really can't do that too much
otherwise they're going to kick you off
the team or they're going to fire you
it's not your job
it's not your role to boss him around
yeah bosses the boss is giving me you
know a full salary so
of course I'm gonna listen to him and I
feel like that when when you're married
it's like if he's showing you that he's
going out and working hard and taking
care of you then you're like yes boss
yes yes yes leader yes leader yes my
king yes my king I cook for you I will
feed you I'll wash your clothes only
only one maybe two meals
if he's doing 100 of the bills I'll do
three meals there we go that's my 10
percent
um but I just I think this is like the
mentality that's gonna leave a lot of
women single and half of us probably
because yeah because I mean there's only
so many like guys that can take over 100
of the bills we're in a modern time like
how can we expect them to take over 100
of the bills if we're not we're not
virgins anymore we're not young anymore
yeah I mean well she still is but but
you know yeah like the average area yeah
but the average age of first marriage
used to be like 22. it's 31 now here
um
but um I quite like being equal you know
like how that sense of power
um as well as the guy but um
if you think of it in a deeper way we
I don't know I kind of jump from one
side too I think I think what you're
saying is when you have children you
don't want to be equal that's what
you're saying isn't it obviously you can
oh no Wednesday I feel like when when it
comes to children and obviously like if
I'm a stay-at-home mom and like it just
depends on the situation it's like
either way I'm the mother and you're the
father and I think
I wouldn't just listen to him if he says
this goes but you wouldn't you wouldn't
listen to him if he says something goes
about my child no because it's our child
if that makes sense but so it's 50 his
DNA 50 your DNA right yeah so if there's
a big decision how do you and you guys
disagree how do you make it uh again it
depends on the situation but I'd always
want to
like someone has to give in do you
expect him to give in or are you going
to give in
good question I always given
um
I think just like do good do good wives
submit to their husband's Authority I
don't think necessarily like if you're a
good wife or a good husband
um I think building that Foundation of
communicating well so if it comes
through an issue of anything and
obviously we're talking about children I
think it's just stating the facts
and then solving it so you both stated
your facts and you both disagree
who who gives in
happy wife happy life
[Music]
it's funny you're not wrong I mean
that's I mean that's that happens all
the time how many women wear the pants
in relationships about to say there's a
lot of men who would literally just do
what their wife says and are those women
happy with them do they usually always
because they don't always
though yeah
go ahead no say what you're gonna say go
ahead say it says okay as much as we
want to be like yeah
um I want to have a say and stuff that
there's times where sometimes you you
want someone to put you in your place
like I feel like so it doesn't make
sense for us to give in Ben yeah I can't
I give it yeah as much I've switched her
yeah
um
sorry darling uh yes because I feel like
when it comes to men I'm Gonna Keep it
nice and short because I can blob on
um so
we expect a lot from a guy obviously
when it comes to women being independent
which again I like an equality to some
extent
um we don't really give that sense
of power to like what means being a man
you know so like responsibility and
you know yeah I know what you mean I'm
not sure if that makes sense but we
don't give them that respect that we
should give them in a way yeah we don't
let them lead to power because he is a
man you know and he has certain duties
that a woman can't do if that makes
sense yeah it's like we want these we'll
complain about male leadership but then
when they're like oh let me leave we're
like oh no no no not like that
sit down as I said because we are never
happy yeah that's not attractive that's
true well that's not attractive to me
what like leadership no a guy being a
pushover like just yeah that's
attractive but that's the problem
because so guys are hit with this dual
narrative aren't they because on the one
hand it's like uh no we won't go you
know equality equality 100 but you know
we we don't want the guy to be sort of
manipulative coercive to be like trying
to you know push us in any sort but but
then on the other hand of course what
women seem to be attracted to most
viscerally is due to uh you know who who
leads indeed to come in and you know
yeah lay down the law so it's sort of
like guys I think a a beset with this uh
you know two two sort of opposing
dialogues coming through you know I feel
like it's energy as well though because
if you don't have that energy I'm not
listening to you yeah simple as that
yeah
there is a certain type of energy you
have to have and there's some guys that
naturally do not have it but then
they're like trying to tell you what to
do and it's like it's getting nice how
do you describe the energy okay it's
exactly It's Just Energy you don't know
when you get it you feel it like you
when when there is a guy who's telling
you what to do and he has that energy
you're like oh wow okay but then another
God guy can try and do that and put on
that act but you feel like it's forced
and you're like this isn't yeah you're
just following the narrative but you're
not actually that yeah not that guy
you're not that guy you haven't got it
in you
sorry
I feel like in those situations you have
to be unapologetically you yeah whether
you're a man or a woman you always have
you want to take the reins or not you
always have to be there and stand your
own ground if you're happy to back down
and be like do you know what we might
both disagree but I think maybe what
you're saying makes sense but I feel
like and that person's willing to go I
know I make sense I'm happy to take the
lead here
that's cool I think it works both ways
yeah I think in I don't think over an
emotional standpoint that a man
overtakes a woman in that but I agree
with you but I also feel like what we're
talking about the energy thing the
problem is with some guys that do it and
we think that they don't have the
energies because they're inconsistent
they're inconsistent for example
say that again say that again like
inconsistent energy yeah yeah so like
sometimes they're masculine and
sometimes they're not yeah sometimes
they're really tapping into that
feminine role and you're like you're
turned off because biologically you're
just like as a woman you're gonna look
for that guy who has that energy could
it be could it be based on how you feel
though that day because we feel
differently every day perceive things
differently yeah I agree yeah so when
you when for example what we talked
about earlier the birth control pills
when she the woman's on the birth
control pill maybe she's more open to
the dude who's less dominant dominating
you know and then
um
yeah could that be correct I I would say
so yeah
it's faster guys hobbing a guy isn't it
I tell you what you know what I mean I
do feel sorry for you guys being a human
who who you said it's hard being a woman
I said that you said that yeah you do
genuinely think it's harder being a
woman and dating than men oh I think
it's so hard but one thing I would say I
feel like men and like their experiences
or their voices it's definitely like
so sad but they're not really shown and
I feel like they should be shown a bit
more do you but I'm gonna go back to the
first statement women have harder time
dating than men yes or no oh wait that
no no no no sorry no offense the guys I
know you guys are struggling no offense
but yeah I feel like they struggle more
you know there there was a woman who
decided to pretend to be a man for a
while can't remember her name but she
ended up killing herself because she she
she did she she turned around and said I
don't know what I was thinking being a
man is horrible and she said that women
completely ignored everything she said
looked down on her judged her on the way
she looked I judged her on everything
that she said and she ended up killing
herself
men's mental health and everything is so
overlooked but but then how is it fair
to say that it's easier to be a woman
but we say that we can't be equal
because we're both so biologically
different is it fair to compare whether
it's be easier to be a man and a woman
or is it exactly but but that is the
first statement that came up no offense
it's the first statement that came up
and it's the first thing that pops into
your head so sometimes you just need to
take back thought and go actually is
that right to say
or do I need to look at it comparatively
I've heard that story before but do you
think do you know much about it I mean
is there any evidence to show that it
was specifically the you know or did you
maybe have some other issues going on
again
yeah yeah in any scientific study you
cannot take away I feel like I feel like
external controllables like you you
can't but in that situation from what
she stated initially was that it was
really difficult to act as a man and to
be treated as the way men are it's just
an interesting look it is not an end-all
and be all of the evidence of supports
it but it's an interesting turn on it
yeah yeah but again I wouldn't use that
as a as a core element of evidence
because it's definitely not the whole
thing about men get what they get and
then as in like men get what they get
but then women can choose I'm not sure
like the whole phrase yeah but I do feel
like I know we always speak about like
how you know we're all saying how like
men it's really hard for them and
everything and yes it is and nobody's
disputing that but I do feel like when
it comes to women I know and I don't
know if anyone would agree with me but
this is how I feel personally I do feel
like the women are more willing to
improve themselves and to do the work
and to try and get better and to become
the best versions of themselves
can you tell me how how do women improve
them so many ways different ways women
are literally trying to work on
themselves mentally like women women are
more open to therapy than men are
they're open to women getting help do
women need therapy more than men do I
think everyone I don't I I don't think
things I think it's the other way around
actually because I feel like if a lot of
men actually went and worked on
themselves they would be able to get the
women that they wanted because a lot of
these men are walking around with
unresolved trauma a lot of issues
okay so okay so I just want to go
through so women go to therapy yeah what
else do we do they do all kinds of stuff
into Wellness
false wrong sixty percent of women here
so no 70 64 of women here overweight
false
you can't be into Wellness if most of us
are fat okay next
oh wow also yeah also I'm talking about
mentally they're trying to fix them so
if they're trying to be mentally healthy
women are there's more women on
antidepressants now than ever wrong
we're not mentally more healthy well men
are doing absolutely nothing right
nothing they're not having anything to
help you do not think that's a societal
lessons Okay okay
they get looked down upon for feeling
that way so they never want to go to
anyone no but that's a narrative that
they created for themselves because
they've told themselves that they have
to be really masculine but no woman has
ever sat there and laughed at her
husband for crying
I wanted to I want you to back up what
you're saying you're saying women women
they're into self-improvement so first
one was wrong second one's wrong what's
next Wellness is not wrong
how is it they are how is it right if
we're fat let's come on okay wait takes
long to to get rid of it okay okay so
then we could look at a challenge
they're trying so so we could look at a
trend of women over time and we're
getting fatter We're Not Getting Thinner
so it's not correct you could think what
you think but it's not right well I
don't know we can look at what kind of
food people are eating but I'm the ones
that make us fat generally women if you
go on social media and you see what
everyone's talking about women are
always asking how do we do this how do
we do that they are trying to fix
themselves because they want to meet
that dream man that's why they run these
dating apps that's why they go to these
dating agencies I'm not getting anything
of substance
like nothing okay they fix themselves so
they go to therapy they're trying to
help themselves mentally but they're
they're on more antidepressants than
ever so they might they might try to do
something but the result like we have to
look at results here we can feel how we
feel but we have to look at results
so if women are fatter than ever we're
more into on more antidepressants they
try to fix themselves like just they
they
but the difference is women can live in
delusion so women can go through life
and not like you know many girls come on
here and genuinely tell me they're tens
do you know me girl you don't you just
don't have men do that and they believe
it I I have I I say I'm an average chick
on my show and girls will look at me
like oh and I'm like most people are
average I've never had a girl come on
here and say she's um slide twice maybe
twice the girls have come on and said
I'm an average girl every girl thinks
they're special I mean the top ones are
the ones men say that about themselves
no no men don't think they're special
because they should no because men men
have to face reality in the world if
they're if they ain't they're gonna
know the world's gonna tell them where
women will they'll say oh you're so
beautiful anyway oh you're a ten of
women we lie to each other too you'll
never tell your friend that she's fat
women tend to lie to themselves though
yes I don't I wear don't get me wrong I
definitely lie to myself every day but
woman will persues themselves as a
person that's wearing the makeup I've
done their hair done this men don't do
that so they look at themselves and they
they may feel about themselves but
they're going that's who I am women will
look at themselves with makeup on and go
I'm a 10 the minute that makeup comes
off they feel so insecured why we are
more like prove it
to help ourselves we are trying to
improve ourselves we'll do anything
um
we'll do anything but the hard
I agree like they won't like lose weight
and things like that why would I push
back on the on the notion that guys
aren't doing anything self-improvement
though because like I'm part of a you
know this whole Space you know these
these guys are I mean maybe it's not the
biggest place in the world but but but
yeah I would agree with that but maybe
you're in an echo chamber you know who
you're looking on Instagram you're
looking a lot of girls maybe they're
into the self-improvement the wellness
they're fine but I'm also I also know a
lot of guys who are also working hard I
mean what do guys have to work on you
know money muscles game frame basically
so you know are you leveling up
financially are you working on your
career are you on your mission are you
going to the gym uh you know are you
looking after your fashion are you
looking after your group so guys do need
to do a lot and the truth is if you are
a reasonably attractive
girl in her say 20s okay we're not even
talking about 10 we're talking about
like a girl who's a six or seven or
whatever five
um you don't have to do very much to get
validation from the dating Market or you
don't have to do very much you have to
be kind of cute wear a summer dress walk
down the street and you're going to get
guys you know who are who are sort of
like complimenting you or whatever
except that's illegal now but you know
back when we used to be allowed to talk
to each other that would you know you'll
get that positive validation whereas
dudes actually for the most part are
invisible to women unless
they've really worked on themselves
unless they've done the necessary thing
and I think if men aren't self-improving
it's women's fault because men have to
be motivated by something
I agree so what do they what again what
do they get at the end of it they get
that women that think it's okay to leave
so what kind of wife are they getting at
the end of it yeah or you get like one
meal a day yeah see if you're lucky oh
you get this whole bunch of guys who
have sort of dropped out the system
because they think the dating is
completely unfair because they think
they're invisible 20 80 of guys are
invisible to women so they think we'll
watch it in cells
they're they're dangerous
things I didn't even know that word
um
I would say that
again it's the fault of women because
again if there's in cells why is that
it's because women are all sleeping with
the same men I I think though just based
on psychological evidence there's
there's a lot going on there that's
deeper than just societal means but I
get what you're saying about like in
retrospect but in cells themselves but
then I also know there's much deeper
side I also don't agree with that
because what you just said I would say
but they all want us to be virgins so
yeah we are sleeping with the same
person or whatever like yeah but why
aren't we virgins because we chose to
have sex outside of marriage and two
guys do not expect a virgin that is the
most I've ever heard in my
life no what do you expect do you expect
a virgin no I don't know I've never seen
a single guy that's at the expects a
virgin I think that's an immature
mindset I think that's the ideal but
they don't I think that's much younger
yeah yeah it's it's much I don't think
it's immature I think men are realistic
I think the whole thing is quite nuanced
though because because to counter what
I've just said you are right there's a
lot of guys who are very very lazy and
they don't want to do the work they
don't want to do anything they
sit there and this is We complain about
this a lot you know they sit there on
the computer going oh it's really unfair
if I'm not a six foot if I'm not a seven
foot five Chad with you know blah blah
blah then I'm not then it's over for me
they don't do anything they just sit
there complaining and you know that that
is on them because also they need to be
going out and they need to be they need
to be working on themselves you know so
I think human beings human beings in
general are inherently lazy most most
people but if again if you are a
reasonably cute you know young woman I
think you get more breaks in in society
than than a dude of the same level
yeah I hear that oh yeah
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super chats guys make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams okay
Geoff thank you for the Super Chat Tomo
a men Improvement channels be be top
five percent women Improvement channels
makeup news rules fashion Carlos all men
can remember the day we could no longer
get help from adults because we weren't
a small kid anymore men have to earn it
on their own Fernando um in this world
there's only one thing that matters hard
facts people misguidedly choose to
accept the truth they are comfortable
with them realizing things that may
things may not we have had expected them
to be unsettled unless it's overwhelming
Jordy if you're leaving for a better man
he will leave you for a better and
younger woman that's a fact
Tomo J Nora Vincent self-made man learn
her name uh Charles uh Stone compromise
is something that can be used to find a
solution where both parties win uh
the Adam Ant these women are average
looking at best the fact that they think
an act like this is a testament to how
screwed Society is today sorry Pearl
thank you for your content I see
Dumbledore wifey sorry girls um that's
not you Erin uh women women select a
tall a man taller Stronger Faster older
wiser smarter and higher income they
want a level-headed confident leader to
protect defend and provide the Proclaim
that then Proclaim that we are equal
follow me question um what do you think
a husband is for keep him in mind
um how much you have thrown around the
word equality before you answer dark
Lane
um uh fruit Freddy um what women fail to
understand is that they manage is is
what women fail to understand is that
they manage the home to a high value man
so it's managing day-to-day operations
of the home
he's out Gathering resources that you
can manage at home
um
blessing their magic and open up the
chat
D um I got my kitchen done recently and
two women did the measurements uh the
men built the kitchen but realized
before we were starting the measurements
were wrong
[Laughter]
um greatness there's no benefit to be a
man in a relationship with a woman with
with no plan of marriage you say
relationships are okay but they're an
excuse to marry
um ladies would you marry a man just
like your father follow me Tyrese would
have been canceled if the rules were
reversed Nathan asked the panel what
type of cat they want in the future
question for the panel if being obese is
being acceptable as body positive should
people that are anorexic be accepted too
it's their choice uh that's actually a
good question Saint man um do good wives
fart and then laugh
um air Nathan Arbor um the lady who is
getting oh I read that one already I'm
gonna refresh it real quick guys
um also guys make sure you sign up for
our Google forum for our next event um I
think we're going to do a meet up in
London um it's going to be a lot of fun
the last one we did um you went to it
right yes yeah yes it was fun
um what was the question that I read up
here that I thought was decent what do
you guys think a husband is for
um I would say a provider
um
um I would say also Man of the House
um as I said before companion to be your
best friend
um also to honestly to push you to be
that better person that is so important
um and a good father I feel like a lot
of no offense a lot of
a lot of men haven't been taught what a
good father is because they didn't have
that experience and that's unfortunate
and that's just being passed down to the
Next Generation to the Next Generation
to the Next Generation and that's that's
something I think is really important
someone that is a good father has good
morals okay uh what do you think
um
I think he's a
protector definitely someone who is
I don't want to say like Shield me from
the world but someone who is gonna have
my back
um
make sure that I'm safe at all times
um emotionally
like mentally financially
um and someone that I can just do life
with like my life partner someone that
can
be by my side and face these challenges
that we face in life together
okay what do you think what's a husband
for
I think
um
I don't know to be honest
I don't know you don't know no it's an
honest answer I don't know
honestly I I don't know but you are
you're from Romania though which is
quite yeah still quite um
what's the word traditional transition
it is does that not have an effect on
how you think about about it not really
okay not really but
um I think we should be friends first of
all
we should get support for each other
we should be equal
think that's important you think men and
women can be equal
there's an intruder coming into the
house are you guys equally gonna fight
him no yes
[Laughter]
I'm ready
I'm gonna run and call the police
you deal with him so no so no okay
anything else oh no you just said you
don't know no okay but you want it to be
equal
So when you say equal do you mean equal
set because a lot of girls say that and
I'm like I don't really know what they
mean by that like they want a partner
equal
I think it's about support and how you
understand each other and when someone
have a bad day you just have to be there
for them and push them up don't push
them down
I think that's important
but what does that have to do with being
an equal
I mean like I know we shouldn't push
each other down in a little bit what is
that
I don't know
you mean like your views are equal kind
of thing yeah like he respects you you
respect him like the discipline between
us like all the respect he shouldn't
tell you what to do and you don't tell
him what to do kind of thing you just
mutually agree we should yeah we should
have a conversation about everything and
just agree yeah but what about when you
disagree what happens we will find a way
then where are you going to listen if he
says
I'm gonna I'm gonna say I'm wrong if I'm
wrong I'm wrong yeah but then so then
you wouldn't be equal right
if if if you guys disagree and then you
have to trust him to make a decision
well
I think she just means that she doesn't
want to like a dictatorship type of
relationships yeah we need to agree we
need to have the conversation we need to
talk about our problems see I don't I
don't think you realize how this sounds
to men
and I I used to say something similar so
I'm not judging you but when you're like
oh we need to talk about our problems
and talk about every issue and like
until we don't really want to lose it no
they just wanted they don't want it like
men just want they just want a girl to
listen yeah okay we're gonna do this and
then she says but why do we do it but
why like men hate that but why it's like
a trick like they hate it yeah that's
true yeah right but I was just curious
um how you expected that to go because
when girls say equal I don't know if
they'd actually want a guy because when
I hear equal it's it just sounds like
girls want a guy that like follows what
they want
I feel like it works more like an
equilibrium rather than equalness
there's more of a wave it kind of goes a
wave yeah rather I think equality maybe
is the wrong toned reason more of an
equilibrium is right and because it goes
back and forth and it's never a straight
line to have equalness is where you will
have problems to say that you're equal
isn't right because you won't work as a
relationship if you're both equal
I'm curious just show of hands and then
I'll go to your I just curious
who here would submit to their husband's
Authority
how old you would okay so it wouldn't be
equal then yeah but he'd be above you no
yeah just to submit you you do need to
be willing to back down and not be equal
anymore
okay so so you say you would though you
would submit well I don't know it's a
tricky one
maybe not okay no I would you would okay
is that what you do now in your
relationship he makes all the decisions
um no
is that just gonna change when you guys
get married or what
if he's a provider yes so if he he pays
all the bills he can decide everything
he's my boss okay uh what about you
you said you would
uh to some extent yeah what do you mean
um I don't know like what it feels
tricky yeah
I'd say to some extent well I think
either way women like well anyway it's
about me so
um if I was a wife I'd I like
the leadership role on his end okay you
know but when it comes to
I think equality is the wrong word but
decision making I like to be part of it
or
um who respects me enough to be like oh
babe you know and uh discuss about
certain things but I would respect his
word for things
um but
I think
I think just being on a general level
that we respect each other
on certain things or most things just to
keep it leveled and to make it work then
it's like oh no I've got this power over
you or it's like me arguing back you
know that makes sense and but answering
your question at the start
um are like a partner in crime and a
best friend I think everyone thrives
um
to get that do you think that's normal
in history that men and women were best
friends
I think mine was the question no the man
yeah the head of the family oh yeah when
do you think that's switched
probably with this generation I don't
know was it like the 1970s or something
do you think that has good outcomes
being best friends with your husband
um
who said yes yeah yeah who who said yes
you did you did
then why are we more divorced than ever
before but maybe that's where my point
comes in of not wanting to get married
so if you're really gonna want to get
married I'm like you have to be friends
with them whether you like it or not
this is the right crowd to be talking in
this channel well she makes it you make
a very good point because because where
all of this is going it's kind of what I
was trying to say to articulate the
beginning which is that is the marriage
certificate fit for purpose anymore
given we've got all these Dynamics going
on in society given there's all these
Divergent wants and needs and people
trying to wiggle out of you know not
wanting to be submit or whatever does it
actually work anymore I'm not convinced
that it does work anymore and I think
the reason it works for you know for
better or worse and there's arguments in
both cases but the reason it worked
before was because society and religion
kept it in place and there were certain
expectations for what you did and now
those expectations aren't there so
everyone goes and says the lines that
pull right out in the church but nobody
really means it and then 10 years later
they're just like oh so bad you know and
that is not a good basis for for
marriage so do we need something else or
do we I mean you know there's a personal
choice here as well I haven't chosen to
get married up to this point largely
because of this stuff you know to be
honest
um or maybe you just haven't met the
right woman well the yeah I mean it
makes you want to get married no I mean
look I mean I wouldn't I never rule
anything out entirely but like I said
I'm not I'm not championing at the bits
oh my God I really want to get married I
really want to sign up to this contract
where I can get half of my stuff taken
away on a whim I mean it's just not do
you know what I mean like I'm happy
um being in sort of long-term
relationships or more casual
relationship whatever but marriage I
mean I mean would you sign a contract
where you only have a 10 chance of
getting your kids if he takes them
and he can take half your stuff
and the house and you'd have to move out
would you sign it
and you only get one and a half meals a
day
I I think if
if their value was very high in my life
then I would take that risk I'm a risk
taker anyway and I feel like if I'm
gonna get something out of that which is
what I really want and which is what
I've always wanted in life which is love
and to be loved I'll take that risk
because that's the purpose of life to be
loved everybody here is searching to be
loved to be wanted and to be appreciated
by someone that is
sorry but I think everybody is searching
for that like everybody in the end just
wants to be loved or find that person
who accepts them for who they are but
why would you need marriage for that
yeah yeah
um you're still being around well for me
it's like I don't know it's like
religion and things like that like
that's something
another thing is you say except for for
who they are but what if it is the guy
who you are is somebody who wants to
sleep around every couple of weeks you
know and sort of have sex with the
Barista or the girl who's working the
nightclub do you know what I mean
because this is a whole other area
because obviously male sexuality is is
you know by and large you know they they
like Pulsar I think earlier you know
they want to have sex with as many
people as possible women have a slightly
different sort of agenda for the most
part
um and then you get into this whole area
where
and I've seen other you know other
podcasts where they talk about this but
like um
you know a guy can really truly love a
woman
um and still go and have sex with
somebody else and that's purely by
that's purely physical yeah and it
doesn't detract from his love from the
woman but but for many women you would
say well well tell me tell me about you
honestly what is it what is your your
makeup it's like well I like showing you
around I mean a lot of women are not
going to accept that you know what I
mean so but that's not that's not like
that's not like by force that's just
like a preference for a man there there
are men who can actually be uh loyal
like they can they can but come on it's
nauseous it's not like something that's
wrong with them or it's like this is who
they are like if most men were in Tiger
Woods position
that's like me saying well I want a
Hermes back you know well she said you
studied zoology didn't you have you got
any input on this I mean do you think
the males generally they look you know
they want to get their underwear I mean
men naturally in like if you look at the
other primates though yes so we are a
primate
um sorry to anyone that doesn't believe
in evolution but we are a primate and
other male primates like chimpanzees
will meet with several females and it's
the biological makeup is to breed
monogamous no and and I don't from
looking back in the evolution of
hominins which is what we are we're a
hominin
they weren't monogamous and it's not
necessarily the way we're made up it's
Society that's done that so for you to
say that someone should always be with
the same person for the rest of them
like their lives huh but if that's not
what they want then so be it don't judge
someone because that's what they're
saying but you know on the other side of
it you're right you're but it's again to
cancel what I just said you are right
because if the guy is also signing up
for that marriage contract then he
should also abide by that contract yeah
you know what I mean but then it comes
back to my question which is well
easy in the guys is it in my best
interest to sign up for it then you know
I do I hear your point I really do and I
do hear your point like why would a man
want to sign up for that paper
um and I I really feel like it just
comes down to the individual and and
what they believe in and I feel like
yeah it is it is to do with religion
definitely I honestly think if most men
knew what they were signing I don't
think most men would do it and I think
if you took religion out of it as well
there's a lot of I know like a lot of
Muslim men you know they wouldn't get
married doing this documentary I just I
can't even believe like the stories I've
heard so they're crazy they're crazy
like guys get screwed over especially I
think it's worse here than the US really
that's shock him it depends on the
statements yeah yeah but I don't I don't
know enough about I've actually I've
learned more about the laws here than
the US now but
um I think we're gonna close out the
show so thank you guys all for coming um
we're gonna do final thoughts so any
final thoughts you want to say speak
your piece on um start here go around
Instagram social medias you want to
shout go ahead okay
um Instagram I think I said that in the
beginning but I'll just saying again um
Kiki underscore chi on Instagram and I
do have a hair page as well
touched by Chi underscore
um but final thoughts
um
I would just say honestly getting
married if you want to get married if
you don't want to get married no one's
forcing you don't get married it's it's
it's as easy as that
um and obviously like culture definitely
does player play A Part
um for example like I'm Nigerian so our
culture is very much get married then
have kids and this this that like
there's not really a I wouldn't say like
your career or like like career isn't
really like a big thing like as much as
education is pushed on to us to go and
get that degree and everything like that
at the end of the day
the end goal
um in my type of coach is to get married
is to have kids and it just depends on
different cultures and
um when you have different cultures
you're gonna have different
interpretations and different views and
everyone has different views that's fine
if you don't want to get mine that's
fine but yeah that's my last thought
um
yeah Instagram cicana TV
s-u-k-a-i-n-a-tv
um you can also find me on Tick Tock
cicana Louisa so yeah
um final thoughts
final thoughts final thoughts
um I would say
let's not forget that marriage is a
beautiful thing and a very sacred thing
I know it's kind of losing its value and
a lot of people don't agree with it
anymore but please don't let that deter
you from finding the love of your life
and making that important decision that
you will ever ever make in your life and
have that experience
um that a lot of people wish for please
don't let that deter you from can I ask
you a question really quick I just feel
like what you're saying is conflicting
what do you mean because you're saying
it's a beautiful thing and it's a it's a
you said something with religion right
like it's a beautiful thing it's yeah
it's linked to a lot of people like yeah
link it to religion yeah but it like
doesn't compute to me if you believe in
leaving if you're not happy
and while I said leaving based off like
a very extreme situation I didn't say
leave just because you don't have
butterflies anymore and then I said
because you argue no okay no no no no
I'm I'm talking like extreme stuff like
abuse and things like that
um but yeah no I don't think you should
leave of course you should try
everything that you can to make your
marriage work and
um
I do believe in sticking it out with
someone and
supporting someone and I think you know
our generation
do just want to move on to the next
thing but I feel like it's important to
remember that really the grass is not
greener on the other side the grass is
greener where you actually nurture it
and you water it
um I agree with that yeah and you know
this whole idea that you know you're
going to move on to the next best shiny
thing that's just a complete fix it's
not real if you find someone that is
genuine is has a good Soul has a
beautiful soul who looks after you takes
care of you that is the most important
thing in life so stop looking at social
media stop wishing that you had this and
that because I feel like a lot of women
are wanting that nowadays and we all sit
here and we talk about sick figures and
things like that but the reality is
social media is pushing that narrative
like we're looking at women who are like
but you shouldn't be with your man you
should be with this man who buys your
Hermes bag and flies you out to Monaco
and Paris and all these places and I
feel like that is literally just a fix
and if you start to look into that you
are never truly going to be happy within
yourself you're never going to be
fulfilled
um because in the end we're all gonna
die and you know they're yeah we are
sorry to be very like morbid but it's
true you know and in the end all you
really have is your memories
and you know the the the the kind of
impact that someone leaves yes and that
is the things that we remember you know
being in love with someone sharing those
Beautiful Moments and those things don't
cost money you know they don't you don't
need money to create those things so
yeah I think really and truly just you
know if you find someone who's genuine
please don't trade that in for just
someone who looks good on Instagram
that's what I'm trying to say like
really look at someone and who they are
inside because that is who's going to be
with you for life that's the person
that's gonna lift you up when you don't
believe in yourself anymore
that was very long sorry
I know we all want to go home
so my Instagram is uh they are uh the e
y a to uh are they called underscore and
X from x-ray
um final thoughts well
you know I think
you should
follow your own feelings and if you feel
like you want to be with that person
just be with that person don't let
anyone change your mind don't let
Instagram change your mind and if you're
generally happy get married thank you
two kids uh
I think all this matter is to be happy
and
um
yeah that's it
okay
um uh Instagram is Laura lakova
underscore X look over is l a c k o v a
um very confusing
um I think in general just like just
enjoy life live life if you want to get
married or get married I like it
uh I think it's it's quite nice to
um spend the rest of your life with just
that one person
um like 34 years I think it's really
heartwarming but again I understand that
the world is different now
um yeah that that that's it really uh be
yourself
um be in the present moment make
memories as a few people said there you
go
um so social media uh at real Troy
Francis on Instagram Realty Francis on
Twitter at realtray Francis on YouTube
and at real try for us on Tick Tock as
well and final thoughts I actually got a
wedding a marriage proposal when I was
last on this show which was the other
day it says uh somebody sent me this
right so it says Troy is handsome thank
you put together and socially
intelligent I wonder if he choose to
marry an average looking traditional
feminine wife or a few prioritize
hotness and looks above her upholding
the traditional standard I'd love a
husband like him so if you're out there
no
it could be just pearly things first
um
I probably prioritize hotness really I
don't know can't she be hot and
traditional I mean I like the honesty
exactly yeah 100 exactly you know
there's someone out there yes maybe
can I come to the wedding I really want
a wedding to go to streaming
oh is it me yeah yeah
um so my Instagram is Lucy underscore
campbell1
um but my final thoughts are just
so level up large now don't worry too
much about things that happen in life
because what's the point
um and don't get married unless you
really thought about it because too many
people rush into that and then
they're destroyed by the end of
it
um too many people don't believe in the
religious aspects of it which is where
marriage comes from if you're not
religious what are you really doing it
for are you doing it for financial gain
are you doing it for yourself are you
doing it for that other person
think about it just actually think about
things before you do it like you know
what I mean
um but yeah that's about the end of my
thoughts I'm very opinionated and I
apologize thanks
okay guys uh make sure you like the
video on your way out and subscribe to
the channel
um a couple announcements before we end
the show um the first thing is that we
have two clips channels just pearly
clips and pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both also guys
um we have a
uh we're doing a apartment tour so make
sure you sign up for our second
membership program like the video on
your way out and we will talk to you
next time